right and we are live
I think the last word with Lord kognito
and Ibaka savant is what is going on sir
uh well you know had a good stream last
night
checked a lot of boxes in one story and
played for a while yesterday worked I
did a insights area - solo took me a
couple couple attempts I had the
internet crap out in the middle of one
of them had a couple unfortunate deaths
pretty far in but finally put that one
together
and then just started playing some
gambit and streaming that for a while
working on some things as I go what do I
need to work on I needed to work on
breakneck never finished that one from
nice forever I go 21 percent delirium
was starting to look like I was like
it's kind of an reach what's there and
then I was like and then so I was
working through those four I was like
okay you need to get my auto rifle kills
that was just using auto rifles like
crazy which auto you used so I use sweet
business for some of it I used gnawing
hunger for some I had like a decent
Tiger spite I could have used but
somebody was just saying sweet business
and it started my own stuff down and
just playing some casual game but not
worrying too much about it
still got my hammer head of course got
to be back actually real quick though
cuz I never got delirium have you used
it yet have you tested it out no oh gosh
I want you to give me the review on that
wants you you know yeah really you put
it to his faces I mean it's nice to have
a legendary arc machine gun for specific
purposes like that but other than that
specifically its I don't know I I hear
pretty decent things because you can
have like 200 bullets in a clip like
crazy stuff so definitely yes was
playing that for a while then had people
jump in and all of a sudden we were like
okay playing with a couple people on my
stream and they jumped into my discord
then we started actually getting
organized and winning I was like alright
what do I need for dredgen but title
moon all the game there yeah looking at
the titles so I was like alright so I
got a couple secrets I'd never picked up
malfeasance just because it was kind of
like I'd really used it waited this far
so I was like now you know pick it up
and give me a boost in level later but
that's one of the secret triumphs I got
that box then I had the one where you
have to have 15 people deposit at the
st. there are four people deposit 15 at
the same time that's the other secret
and then the one that actually took me
longer because I kept forgetting is to
win a match which with all gambit
weapons equipped oh yeah it was like
going through going through and be like
art remind me in the end I'll switch my
weapons over it works as long as you do
right before your last round that you
win switch those over got that so
literally last night I have a video just
recording of turning everything in of
getting malfeasance 21% delirium break
Nick and dredgen title I was just like
that's powerful that's a lot you eat you
eat man I'm proud of you man Oh seesaw
be working yeah that's a big title
that's a lot of commitment I gotta give
you credit the annoying part is outside
of a like lore bones and eggs that I
haven't really shot the eggs because I
always wonder if I'm ever gonna do a
video all I really need once I just kind
of start knocking those out is gonna be
the still the silver Tercel the ship and
I can have curse breaker yes bear oh
sorry I did the sparrow and then I need
I've got I'm getting close to wafer as
well so see if I can get a few titles
and pins trying to look like I actually
know what I'm doing since putting in
some work a little bit in between other
things what about you your hiatus from
the world of destiny and all things that
is yeah yeah so much for that what
happened there sir well it's all good
now listen you know I was I was talking
very heavy last week so it's deserved um
you know anything like I don't initially
just jumped on to kind of like check out
I think it was sort of like some type of
armament
number with the new deluna's nerf yeah
so I'm Sydney I'm playing in my attack
so I was like I was so close to getting
it but then revelry have him so I was
like I'm not playing calm that's not
having it so while I was like one of
forums I'm like wait a minute
a service revolver that's evolving so
viola has which is the what is it the
180 yep okay I might follow has a
possible God roll out there in the world
exactly so I said you know I didn't get
service revolver yourselves check out my
strikes I'm gonna know what I could
start grinding towards that cuz I
haven't been grinding strikes as much as
I should have some being crucible a
little bit too much so that's how the
ball started and I just was like alright
I'll just try to grind out strikes
whenever just staying pay me do it play
like he boxes today II PvE don't touch
we you know it's gonna be hard but just
try to do it with the whole goal of
getting service revolver to prep for no
lunar than Lulu's nerf
so as I'm playing your desk is a funny
game soon as I start playing boom to
tell Fox oh really really bad get me all
my exotics now that I've been you're
dying after yeah oh you're just like oh
I haven't played in a while this and
he's like oh you you haven't logged in a
while let's throw them a couple bones
and see if we can get the hook back in
they would literally donate they told me
that they'd throw me home what's your
self nautical umm what I'm saying
through oh oh there's a warlock exotic
chess it's like amorous and green
alchemy yes and welcoming I know what
you're talking about yeah alright let me
give y'all now here's where we're really
all the way I started blazing cuz I
started I got to tail and then I got
sanguine now I'm gonna give you our
warlocks some game right now listen up
warlocks and give y'all some game here's
the deal he throw us and green you throw
on the stormcaller than debuffed old one
bottom tree the one that gives you um
you know the our souls last longer the
one that when you're around people your
riff goes up you play that in pvp right
because I did I've been there huge
all you'll be doing is living around
other people getting your risk then when
they're in their wrists and you're in
the wrist you can see you know in your
what you call you can see through walls
they can see through wall it is the
ultimate team like like support
person if you're not good in PvP because
you're literally helping your team
you're giving them our souls you're
healing them and you're giving them
sight beyond sight to look through walls
and do stuff so it's not like antenna
vision but man it definitely is nice to
just see especially on certain Maps -
there's something where it's less but
there's some work man it's huge mm-hmm
so I had that then I threw some long
path I started specking it I was like
doing some like Paragon mods you know so
I'm like I'm just getting riffs all day
I was obnoxious it was so fun so much
fun with that is the last day on Bana
you boy with crazy did you see the clip
you see the clip
I think I did yeah it was pretty good oh
man nice little 35 piece it was war it
was it was real sweet huh yeah I'm
feeling good I have my mom my vigilance
I had my bug-out oh man so I started
with that like I said it's been planned
and once I've been doing the strikes and
getting towards that it's just started
dropping for me and the only thing now
that's left literally isn't when I Cesar
when I use my fated if he's got to give
me one of those exotics now because the
only breed that are left
what are you all wrong you know that the
magic trio which is Geo mags still have
Phoenix Protocol still don't have and um
what's the third one
oh man it's one more one more oh my lord
Lord was so yeah pretty good checklist
one of those is gonna help something
yeah man that's it but yeah that's been
nice I've been like I said playing just
getting into grind again just like
having my logo and last thing I'm
playing a lot of all armory a lot of
black armory having a lot of fun with
that I'm just grinding out some also
grind so I want that ship um oh yeah
yeah what you talking about no my
brother I feel like my brother even
worked to try and get close to that and
I don't know if he got it I forget what
it takes to get it
mm-hmm just a stupid number of like go
fan of these puns read um forage things
yeah yeah so ticks I'm grindin well hey
you know like my grind has been I mean
I'm about four months too late on
breakneck but I finally got the thing
but yeah
did you guys
using them right neck is beautiful ma'am
telling that as we do I'm in pulled the
rampage spec put it straight in still
having a you go it just literally locked
it in already went straight though you
was already a heavy gate you know what
to do I know what to do with that one
yeah so guys I don't know what to put in
21 percent earlier and we'll figure that
one out that's what I guess was pretty
much been it for us it's weird we've
actually been playing some destiny what
is the head no what are you doing yeah
but before we get to too deep in destiny
talk which will not really be too much
on swab it's very light got to talk
about anthem I'm gonna talk about the
the funeral service that is currently
going on for the game though no I mean
so basically what's going on the words
have been out there quite a few
developers name developers and main
leads on anthem are shifting to Dragon
Age 4 mmm they're kind of turning it
over to the live team they've launched
this thing they've kind of seen what
needs to happen which is a ton and we
all know it but it's like that gameplay
loop is there but it's like they just
need to work on a lot of stuff and as we
kind of said before I think many people
out there may agree they just need to
pull like a Diablo Reaper of souls the
division 1.8 whatever it is to like sit
back do a whole bunch of stuff turn this
game into something either use this to
build into like anthem to hope that that
might actually be something or just take
the time to make a ton of content and
release another piece later because
everything's basically delayed the all
the progression the Cataclysm all that
stuff is delayed there's no real date
for it so then with major developers
leaving what do you think about that
what do you think of them like the
larger chunk come in there's some that
are staying but quite a few are moving
on yeah it's pretty sad I mean obviously
when I heard the news you know um you
know article went out and you know I
talking about these guys are moving off
development two tracks in each floor and
then you're just like man you know it
really it really hurt because you saw
the names you remember those names right
Amy were like you know Chad's and I've
got Auto voice name the other two but
pretty much those three the name
were involved when the guys that were
kind of on Frontline for anthem that
would they would talk to the community
every day you'd get the updates so to
see those names say hey you know they're
kind of moving on you know it did sit
well with me I'll be honest you know
it's very tim is it's not even angle
somebody just said like I'm just like
when I heard that my pan like this is
kind of early you wanna me and you know
I thought they would be a little bit
more committed to it but as I'm getting
more information and then all my bleep
Chad Robertson no hadn't been Irving bin
Irving I think is still there I saw so
those two you know me still there in
Irving was active on Twitter like he was
alone on one of the ones I saw the most
so very much so very much so I think
there's no long Austin yeah yeah really
Boston right yeah yeah so when I saw
Chad tweet today I mean actually after
that afternoon was yesterday night um he
made the statement we're still a hundred
percent committed to anthem looking
forward to showing players new content
working on we want to make sure we're
promising so updates on what's coming
and again when we focus home you have
things near completion
and then he continues and he says him
and Ben they've got a big team between
Austin and Edmonton to focused on
motivated for improving the game we
appreciate your support and for being on
a journey with us so the vibe I'm
getting is yes this thing is
transitioning to a live team but at the
end of the day they're not completely
going away from it yet
so what would hope you know I'm saying
that whoever is still working on the
game that they still have a role map in
place for that turnaround looked at 1.8
or that you know dîablø kind of thing
where they're taking king yeah we need
some taken king moments you're all like
that's what they need you know so you
just you just hope that it's not lip
service and that it's actually going to
happen and there's still commitment to
the game because I was talking to people
on Twitter like you just want you know
what I'm saying like you just want to
see them not give away something that
has a great foundation you want a game
like this to get a sequel right because
we both agree the flying is fun the
classes are great the game you know
graphically is good so at least on PC
you know what I was saying is just like
you know you just don't you don't want
it did that man so yeah I mean that's
kind of one of those pieces to its like
it's hard to watch I haven't really
jumped back and never really totally
maxed I know a couple friends they got
so basically max level kind of played it
out but at that point they I mean even
Paul Tassie's like there's one thing to
grind out mostly but it's gonna be your
most efficient when you get to the top
and I'm just like I could doubt you know
dude normal stuff and kind of play
through and get some drops and see but
and that's just kind of the weird thing
at this point they're not letting at
least the people that are playing just
do you have a lot of loot like they're
not just cranking that up to like you
know three or four X and just throw and
leave it at home because it's still
random roles like anything else and let
a few people that are play and have fun
mmm yo somos drop that now get honest he
said I'm and chat he said Jason Schreyer
said the main leaders hitting up an two
minutes and we plan on transitioning to
Dragon Age 4 well before Anthem launch
so this could be something like I said I
mean you know something like like some
more same way so I'm ready in the in the
works and almost like like destiny I
would say like a Luke Smith and
Noseworthy right
they started off at the launch and then
ultimately you don't see them anymore
and they going off into destiny 3 so
hopefully is that situation and they
already had that transitionary process
in place and it's not as bad as it looks
because optically slow-mo it just didn't
feel good you know I'm say just to see
that you're like wait is it gonna happen
is it not gonna happen like are they
gonna are they dropping it is he a
walking away so I mean I agree I think
that's probably what is happening you
just want to see the follow through you
just want to see the commitment to the
roadmap and and move forward with it so
and that's what will happen sometimes
with just rumors and information going
around it's like some like people on
Twitter will say like hey I'm moving on
down stuff like this in people like you
know larger Minds I'll put together say
hey these four people all work at this
one place what's happening and something
like that'll happen but then you know
when he said there and says it's like
you know this was planned before it even
started okay like that was that was an
expectation that they know and they're
like yeah this is totally fine is what
we're expecting got this thing off the
ground live service we're going on to
the next thing
but and like our eyes were like oh this
person's leavin this person's leave an
enemy here just people talking around
the internet and spreading random tweets
and stuff like that it's almost like
rumors to say oh everything's on fire
they're throwing anthem in the bushes
and all this other
means I've listened to too many LPS ah
yeah because I love it I'll be bush leg
man okay you know but that's kind of one
of those things that works as a perfect
segue into what we've been playing you
know the cars in the cars in the street
clearly uh they they have opinions about
it
so I'm sorry your question repeat your
question sir yeah no but it's just as we
take a whole bunch of people leaving a
studio to go on to do something that was
planned right and it's not a big deal
but in on in Twitter's mind and things
like that it's like it's a big deal and
then you turn it on flip to destiny got
like four or five people leaving again
you see Hamrick just like man I've been
doing stuff for like eight years I want
to take a break and do other things and
it was like and I think Hamrick and what
was new ski are like actually doing
something together but you see like my
heart I love me some Joe strong oh man
yeah it's like I mean a lead writer you
got Claud Jerome and then Joe gross all
those guys zoom desk from Bungie have
left within the past six weeks or so
which is quite a bit and everybody's
like what's happening over there is it
good is it bad
em test-video out and I was like the
same thing like same thing it's like I
mean from was key it's like they've been
doing something for eight years whether
they're I got to a good spot and I want
to take a break and do my thing whether
it's right like some of it is like
Kuwait is coincident there's a lots
coming together at the same time and
maybe they know things that we don't
good bad or otherwise right but again
it's just like things do get spun
drastically out of proportion and social
media does that a lot
it's one of those pieces that I don't
know it's like takes always just like
pull back a second and think it's like
there are certain reasons so it's like
five people you know pretty close
together to guys that know each other
that are pretty much in every video
together leaving and doing a project
together that's just their choice right
like that one's there's some of the
other ones like you gotta wonder but you
know no I hear you saying just to
expound on it it's just like I'm you
know I tried not to jump to conclusion I
hit obviously when you you know it was
something you care about
obviously destiny we care about studio
we care about you
so when you have these people that
you've grown or cut these names that
you've grown accustomed to seeing right
you you definitely have that attached
for sewing like damn this one's gone so
I guess with me it became you know at
first yes I've made I make jump
conclusion a little bit like yo like why
what's going on like all of them at the
same time like you know and like the
thing is like you said I mean it could
be very well you know that these guys
have been a long time they are moving on
I will say this though
whenever you see multiple on again this
is speculation when you see multiple
people that leave in at one time right
sometimes it's a pre-emptive move before
something else happens right so let's
just say you're in the corporate world
or whatever and you're hearing you know
hey things is gonna be restructured or
you have a new CEO or in bungees case
they're on their own right so who's to
say you know they may have pretty
primitive information in the future as
far as the roadmap or how things are
gonna sustain going forward and they say
hey you know what maybe the time I need
to put resume out or hey maybe good
things just happen to come along right
at that time and they transition also
out at the same time so lets you know at
the end of a bungee is a huge companies
like 700 plus employees yeah so all that
I heard you know listen I get it you
know these are really really big names
and you know let's see what's up but um
I'm not gonna get crazy yet and I just
need to see more of opulence and
whatever September or if it even comes
out in September as we've discussed
another game that is in that month that
slo-mo is over here talking very
strongly about okay so first piece like
revelry ends on Tuesday thank God what
you do all what you do how much not play
the rubbery I did everything I could in
my power to avoid it that's how much I
love that it still got you it still got
you I didn't touch you I believed every
that once I wouldn't have known you
playing a game with crucible involved is
what I'm saying and that's the worst
part of revelry oh no no I I played I
played on you right I played I am ban
his final day yes I know and I stayed
out of it I stayed out of that after it
went away and I've been all PD or PV hey
I got a knife all got out there for you
I want to see you say hello I you got a
solo a nightfall you got a cell
okay ISIL I've never done it I've never
done actually need to do that you're
right I was like there's enough out
there they're like hey I've watched the
videos looks like I got the guys I
wouldn't do inside terminus I wouldn't
start that hour though well that one
even took me 22 minutes okay I was like
and I still I was like I got like 113 or
whatever so I mean I got over the mark
but it was more like yeah there are the
ones that are like I can probably point
you to an easier one but I want to get
that tweet and be like yo hit that solo
final sound right I'll get it done okay
I got some bills I want to play around
yeah oh yeah in the world of destiny we
know there are some people who have left
but it's like honestly we've got revelry
ending on Tuesday what's next yeah the
drops no no I was literally like I'm do
which some you guys are and you guys can
definitely tune in on aw do you know
we're on Google podcast iTunes and
Spotify are there too big pretty much
everything and pod be no to so if you
can't find us on one of them cool look
on another word on a lot guys but yeah
it's like I'm basically shrugging my
shoulders to basically say I don't know
for May 7th to June 4th whatever the
date is we were talking about before
like yeah June 4th is the first Tuesday
so we got four solid weeks of I don't
know
yeah and they he'll look to it in the I
will say this they allude to it in the
12 it will get into about the silence so
it's like okay you know we got we got to
know something cuz ain't nothing really
going on and then yeah this is this is
very interesting I was seeing this
approach between seasons yet yeah it's
like they I mean we knew this was the
lighter season we kind of guess that at
least with drifter content not a big
expanse of other stuff they're not the
forges were spreading out those other
things it's it was just drifter and then
we got the revelry and then it's like
what are the dates when does opulence we
have a month and the way they've been
dropping the
stuff for the previous season is like
the week before they'll tease a little
bit two weeks before and then the week
before they can drop what's going on but
if opulence is all these secrets and
everything then I got nothing i got
nothing bro it's very interesting to me
I don't know I really know this is
uncharted territory and hopefully like I
said we'll get it to the table and stuff
we could try to piece this thing
together because yeah this is this is
strange to me yeah so in the swab it was
a light one
but in cool at cool things that do
happen sometimes the shattered thrown
right along so I got to watch about half
of it and ostomy the half I watched was
cool just because I love that place so
much fun I ran it the other day actually
on Tuesday
literally started it at like 11:30 on
reset and it went through I was in there
for like two hours and then did my
weekly reset stop so I was fine and then
but yeah watch it halfway I got about
halfway through and just having them
talk about like the art just kind of a
cool way when you go into the shattered
throne and that's what it's like I
didn't even get to Vora gap I didn't get
to the two boss fights so I didn't
actually get all that far but the cool
thing they described and that's what
they wanted to do and they described
like a postcard and they said postcard
basically like your single shot image of
kind of the area of what you're going to
it's just like an artist concept thing
but in the postcard it was literally
from where you're starting all the way
to the top of that spire tower and they
said literally in that instance where
you start at those steps as you go down
into Erebus with all those symbols and
everything the tower you see at the top
that's exactly where you're going
really yeah that is exactly where you
end up because if there's a point on in
the descent where you can because that's
the second part with the catwalks and
the little mini ogres in the shadow
thrall area if you when you enter the
descent before you go down the rocks and
you look straight through the entire
Canyon you can see the doorway you're
gonna go into to the for gas fight you
can see it all wow that's pretty though
that's yeah so like I love that yeah
it's really cool to see the scale just
kind of look around in there and see you
like alright so I'm gonna go out over
here I'm gonna cross back over the left
go through this over here cross over
there
head up those and it's just like really
cool to watch and see that they planned
all that stuff out so I love to seeing
stuff like that man I definitely I know
that one
definitely holds a special place because
it's like it was first of all it was a
surprise
yeah it's borderline a mini raid or four
three play it plays and it's just really
cool man it's absolutely really cool to
see something like that and I'd like to
get behind the scenes stuff like that oh
my lord
Doug Forte's going in in the jack man
like I am right now deaf of my light I
favor I saw was two weeks the game is
like watching paint dry
listen bro I feel you I'm with you the
only thing that got me to reinvest if
only I can tell you is start what I call
like doing clean up things that you know
that you're gonna need in preparation
for patches bugs or just in general of a
new season and literally that's what
I've been doing like that's why my
service delivery quest on it going you
know saying that's why I've been
cleaning up things as far as on like the
for being the armory stuff weapons I've
been trying to work on loadouts and
Bill's literally that's what kind of got
me going but it doesn't interest you
like II said it's okay it's definitely I
know I had to say that the games
actually quite a few speaking of another
game that we're gonna be touching so
we've got season of opulence June to
August we don't know a damn thing about
it
mm-hm seriously like we don't know
anything about season of opulence said
we have some six player match made
activity supposedly but like just like a
road map change before it may change
again we don't know I'll be curious what
that one's called but people have date
of mind what that thing's gonna be
called and then gonna have a raid so
that's cool
that's one everybody looks forward to
nice have the raid have the raid race
that'll last for you know the raid raced
is like really like one day on Twitch
Lake bubble and the way they typically
go lately they've been quick and then we
don't know we don't know what's next we
know if you read Paul Tassie's articles
September has been something in the
world of destiny every September but
early September Nell has a giant giant
roadblock and quotes I gotta say like so
we're gonna talk about Borderlands 3 now
for a minute let's get it have the way
the confidence they had to do their
gameplay from the very beginning to
explain what was going on and set up
that way to have streamers just live
stream a version of their game and not
have it break is a whole lot of like
whole lot of play testing whole lot of
QA and a whole lot of confidence to know
that their game that people are going to
stream live not like a cookie cutter
here's this thing you can't really screw
it up make your content here no just go
explore and like see what happens and it
from what I saw if everyone's loving it
like nothing really broke everything's
good so in its and it's just more
Borderlands which is what most people
they're not trying to do the live
service model they have a billion game
of guns or whatever like guns with legs
and crazy stuff but I mean quality of
life they said from people like the
shooting isn't but like destiny level
it's not that level but they said it's
definitely a lot better it's closer it's
getting crispier the the art style could
be a little divisive on stuff because
it's the cel-shaded not as a kind of
detailed but I mean it does it'll still
probably look pretty good depending on
what you're running it on and they just
had more bosses than ever more content
going to other planets on your ship that
you've got so I mean it's gonna be big
and it's and this is one that hasn't
done anything in seven years I think
highly anticipated yes so everybody's
ready for this so yeah so are you a
Borderlands person I am NOT a
Borderlands person not because I don't
like the game I believe when it came out
it was right around the time when arm
was something else came out during the
time and I was completely wrapped up and
I came out late with it but I ended up
playing it and I really did enjoy it I
really enjoy the gunplay it was nice and
I'm a sucker for cooperative experiences
so it really resonated with me in that
level
and then like it was crazy because I
played the game I'm like okay cool but
you know what I really got into the game
playing the telltale version of tales of
the borderlands have you played that bit
that day let me tell you that is one of
the best telltale games
it is absolutely hilarious and it puts
you in the universe so now I understood
it helped me understand what the the
feel the tone of Borderlands really is
because I really was fraudulent with the
story I heard about Pandora I really
didn't know what was going on but it's
so funny it doesn't take itself
seriously and I just thought a gap like
that moment I've never played a game and
you have moments and you just put the
control that and you erupt and laugh I'm
like this gameis it's like silly like
but it's it's what it is man it
represents their personality it's all me
I shot the slow-mo tails and boy lands
one of the best I see some dude that
look like rise rhy is that character
slow let me know if he is in part 3 but
um for things that sell Randy it's gonna
loot a shooter that shooter Louie yeah
when he says that shot the ready pitch
mister microtransaction himself but uh
but now back to borderlands like the
game looks fun I've watched a couple of
gameplay streams shout out to all the
people who got sent out there um I watch
I lose your game I had one man he looks
fine man they look funny cuz look great
the abilities look great now here's the
thing what I actually like really a
destiny and me smile was the stopping of
that loot ninja stuff so that the drops
are now to you and your specific love
you don't have to worry about someone
that that's like a boar man's thing like
people come in Luton and you take your
stuff and then like after a drop so as
with us as destiny players we don't ever
have to deal with that like tailored our
engrams are tailored to us we're gonna
get what we get there's not this match
scramble to go underneath you know a
Theon and then take engrams away from
other like that's immortal and stuff
lying about that layer I know Oh
slow-mo he said yes he's in part three
he's running at all I like Ron Schott
slow-mo man that's my guy he's giving me
game it rises a character in details for
the borderlands series that i
really got he's absolutely last he's
like them one of the main characters so
he's telling me he's in the game so yeah
but yeah I like what I saw it looks fun
the cell shaded the graphics look good
you know on PC is gonna be fantastic
next generation consoles insert than
before okay or what have you and I'm
ready
so the billets get to meet of it which
is September yeah I mean it's gonna hit
September 13th
that's when typically with exhibitions
and a we're gonna hit this September
schedule because Call of Duty is couple
months later and this is what we're
gonna do we're gonna space it out Bungie
doesn't have to do that anymore and now
they're staring at this so being that
history says that ghastly I've taught
policy eloquently bro
everybody's in my camp at least we're
gonna give this is your day to shine
this your day to shine so we go really
black
so historically every destiny release in
the fall has been September that is just
what it has been this is a transitionary
year and we know they're on their own
the question is advances does destiny be
to move their date let's go yeah I mean
if there's smart and don't want to get
swallowed up by the giant thing that is
Borland's cuz honestly you have some of
your biggest people on Twitch that are
gonna go straight to Borderlands your
gift aliens your Broman some your big
streamers they're gonna be a lot of
people who want to play it and then you
take the people people like dado people
like others that are gonna do raids and
things they're gonna want to go where
the big views are I mean they still have
business and popular they have to kind
of follow certain trends because they
are big enough to do that a smaller
streamer smarts actually stay on destiny
and actually be like hey I'm gonna see
what else is out here and do this and
not go try and play with the big boys
because you're just gonna get buried on
like the 20th page but the bigger ones
who can play they're gonna so quite a
few people are gonna jump in there so I
mean yeah estas we're saying either
August which I don't think is I don't
honestly don't think August is an option
because we have season of opulence
already
like determine out to be there so you
have June through August already set and
at the end of that two weeks later
you've got Borderlands mm-hmm so then so
what do we do what do you do I think I
think I got a strategy okay right okay
gotta go meet with Pete Parsons and see
what we got what's Bungie I always
forget
I thought penis Bungie you made me write
yeah so isn't it
all right here's the deal now we know
that they've historically always done
they can't okay the game's not in that
in that place right now um content-wise
what might save them is because of the
annual pass structure and the fact that
normally we never get content in the
summer so when it's operas we're gonna
see what June 4th probably would be my
bed if I do yes okay so I guess that's
every three three moon sorry every three
months we've had a season so all right
so we got June yeah they can't because
at the end of day that means July August
September every another three months you
you have to do what was the game that
did that this year that move what do
they call a duty they move from Red
Death this year last year absolutely
does you've got the bimini you are you
if you drop with poor limbs the seven
years whatever it's been in the making
you know completely in its own lane and
here's the thing let's be honest II like
Destiny's been very fortunate with
memory because we all we all did I had
you in ILP you know last year and we
talked about that infamous you know
destiny versus division versus you and
I'm saying now don't get me wrong
division is doing this thing right
there's no doubt about a division
eschewing this thing but we're sealing I
know ready right and we we have
established that the destiny player in a
division player for the most part are
separate people okay
anthem was kind of that game everybody
oh this might be the one you know I'm
saying and we've seen by hassel an atom
right so now into Borderlands this is
the threat the established history you
understand it's in the space Lulla sure
guns fun like
they know what they do and they do it
well they're not trying to do anything
else but what they do that is going to
kill that base you see half of the
majority the Destiny community being
flat thrown out there these guys love
the game and I'm saying like the taxis
the cactus that bro me like you said all
these guys I like briars and Tufte I
know they went in there half a DCP it's
like there's a lot of people in the
dusting world that are going yeah so you
can't they can't I mean I think I'm very
curious to see how they handle it cuz
you know I think you have to blink you
gotta bend a knee you gotta survive the
storm
so you gotta come out in that October or
normally I'm a pulling about whenever
it's ready no you can't because you
gotta stay away this is where I wanted
to get into that talk because yeah
October November is when other heavy
hitters like Borderlands is still it's a
four player co-op experience there's no
real it's not meant to be live service
they're not gonna keep adding stuff
there's a point some people will like
play through their time and Borderlands
for a month or two some people still
grind it out and do multiples but it's
like your first playthrough does have a
fine relatively in relative end point I
mean there's gonna be lots of planets
and tons of stuff to do but there's a
relative end point so that
october/november still gives space for
those games that's why activist you even
played the same card the way destiny and
Call of Duty would one thing you do
potentially get in Call of Duty which is
rumored to be modern warfare 4 which is
know nothing to totally balk at you've
got Star Wars of The Fault like what
does it fall in order so I mean that's
gonna be your decent sized game there
for single-player people you've got Call
of Duty coming for shooters and we still
don't know what else obviously we
haven't seen III yet and things like
that so where does Bungie squeeze in
what do they squeeze in what do they do
it's got to be October you got a deal
October October for the most part you
might have some single-player experience
it you know let's look at let's line up
the competition right I mean generally
October you figure sometimes battle feel
the drop I don't know if they're gonna
drop this year you know I'm saying based
on what's going on I got a look at the
lineup but I mean I I think I'm told
is is the safe month because you avoid
November of the crazy because November
is gonna be like I said you got your
Activision releases you got your new
call of duty you got to stay out that
lame you cannot compete with them in
that space September I mean even if you
try to that you can't make the mistake
of doing early September because it's
gonna happen get probably you only get a
week before you're gonna get like a wig
two weeks your population is out of here
Dan I mean you could I guess if you
really want to be risky what is it
they're like sixteenth is born in let's
pull up the calendars right Orleans 13th
13th right so I'm looking at some low
right now stuff now I know the date all
right so it's September 13th these are
yeah so that's a Friday okay so this
September 13th which is second week you
can't come out I mean you can be cute
and trying to drop it but honestly you
got a hit October 4th or 11th this way
you give yourself that three week the
four week buffer let the community get
it in get it out they say I mean it's
not gonna get out this but completely
but at least you can you can weather the
storm
you cannot come out later to ladies
thinking well they're gonna do a Tuesday
so it's the first are they into the 15th
so yeah so yeah they're gonna do it too
exactly so you you you got to be yeah
you gotta be the eighth or the 15th this
way you get October you get a cool month
rock out November comes you still okay
gonna be that cold do is gonna do what
it do but yeah you have to man you you
cannot play around well what comes in
October um hopefully a comet but I know
most likely it's not gonna have yeah I
mean like the question now is to yeah
you see people even bungee you're
wondering a is it a big deal or they're
all that's like I mean dusty whatever
that still in the works like that's been
in the works forever live service pieces
whatever they're gonna do is net is
gonna be oh you're good
no but yeah just live services gonna
maintain what they've got and I I wonder
if I'm still like they do need to
address their community I think cuz
we've we've had this discussion multiple
times we don't need to hash it out again
they just need to address what's going
on whether they say but this is one of
those like before I get to what I was
about to say
when I say go another thing hmm so like
previously like we were talking about
like mine share and stuff like that with
like destiny not putting out content
people going away mm-hmm how much mine
share do you think Borderlands was
really worried about and mine share is
not even the right word people aren't
gonna forget about destiny in a year
it's not like if somebody's like oh
doesn't III got an ounce what's that
game they know exactly what the hell the
game is no I'm just saying like no but
as a troll that's not no but okay from a
realistic standpoint that's oh that's
truth right if you bunt destiny threes
announced next year what's that of
course everybody knows what destiny is
people know what Borderlands is from
seven years ago people knew what the
bigger games are so I mean they're not
gonna forget what the game is oh so
they're not getting okay no I'm just
saying like I mean as he said Johnny
saying destiny 3 has to drop September
2020 and that I think everybody is on
board whenever the consoles drop
whenever all that is I think d3 comes
there but it was like honestly like
whether it's just a smile it's I got a
feeling like the small annual pass is
probably what they're gonna if this
weird time shake is now what they're
looking at
I mean do they want to try and leg it
depends it's already in the works that's
the sad part
there are three months away from
whatever's gonna happen we're just all
speculating yeah whether it's a front
loaded and you'll pass and they bump it
a month whether they just stick with
September and say hey and still here
guys when you come back come back
vagabond oh saying March March for what
vagabond a vagabond those want some D's
on d3 at March he's on his feet
yeah oh right now he's going off and be
interesting yeah okay so what I was like
what if that okay fine we've hashed out
the other argument you know great heavy
yeah yeah what if d3 actually did a
March what would like that's only a six
month gap just give a live service time
to maybe do a couple live events and
things like that maybe you don't do a
lot and then you have six months and
then when not a lot is planned for that
time they swing but it's a good move to
come out yes your I agree with you in
the month to come out but I disagree I
do not want to come
in March and the reason why I don't want
it coming out before the next-generation
consoles because Maya no that's the
point - yeah we need to have it in
unison and we need the next-generation
consoles to have a fresh start
so that PC and cross-play and everyone's
one big happy new one though that's what
they initially wanted before the
PlayStation Fiasco again so you know I'm
with you man I I think no more push that
bad boy
you know December it out actually I can
be cool it's gonna sound crazy yeah I
can be cool because it is a little scary
to launch to me destiny at the same time
of next generation consoles but
everything is scalable so maybe I'm
overreacting but if they could do fall
and make me get to cross generation
release you know saying well the old
consoles still have it lasts as long as
it doesn't mess with it though as long
as it's not like voltage basis because
of Xbox 360s memory I'm like you can
kiss me I'm at you can say that again
yeah too bad for those dudes we were
playing the big boys but I mean no
disrespect but yeah you gotta do that
but in reference to September dude stay
away any guy they cannot they cannot do
that they cannot come out anywhere close
to this game and I'm one that I've never
blinked when it comes to destiny I'm a
personnel when dusty drops I don't care
about whatever that game boylan is the
game that should have to fear I mean
it's it's not a it's not a Live service
long Lester it's some people that will
play it a lot and have multiple
playthroughs but it is a force in that
timing space that they usually occupy
that now basically bleeds into the crazy
fall October November that is packed so
I mean if you okay so then as Bungie
looks at they may have heard about you
know things come in whenever this got
announced and stuff like that so for
their value proposition for the content
they put in what if they're I mean
they're front loaded annual pass and
things like that
but what if that front load now gets was
shifted to like another month what if
they start the Annual Pass smaller the
kind of weeds
these few months and then they say maybe
December or January then they're bigger
pieces like hey we're gonna do this
Annual Pass I mean honestly it'd be
hilarious if they would ever actually
just say we know there's like 16 other
big games coming out right now
we're not gonna fight for your time
because we knew you guys want to do that
but when those things die off towards
like Christmas or January we want to
give you guys a decent chunk of content
as we wait towards September like it's a
solution
go away completely after ah who know
like baby like if they do say an annual
pass but say instead of everybody
thinking it's front-loaded mm-hmm and
you might just get lost in the mix right
do something small almost like again
like yeah hopefully not quite like that
some of the season of The Drifter to do
something smaller maybe best with lure
little like one-offs here and there and
then maybe in January that's when you
get your bigger shot of something like
kind of as you wanted your maybe your
comment so it's kind of a small lead-in
and then give them either the rest of a
smaller like life service thing to fill
out the year or something like that one
more time when do you want that smaller
the smaller starts like September like
the smaller stuff starts like also you
say like okay just like me like hey this
is a baby thing play it off and on like
every you know nesting people still like
you know you see dado still logs onto
xenu's like stuff like that people are
still gonna do a little bit here and
there so smaller thing like maybe a
gambit just a mode or something to kind
of like fill space and as you oh as
you're trying to go for don't completely
leave the world a little bit here but in
January when the space is there then
they give you a bigger shot when you've
got time to jump into something maybe
larger maybe I mean they've got so many
options at this point the nice thing is
they have the flexibility to choose what
they want to do but man I don't know
what they're gonna do yeah I mean this
you know how I mean it's dangerous
dangerous um I was like well okay let me
ask you this mm-hmm you want to comment
say if they do their standard schedule
when would you like if comets in
September 4th its swallowed up or swept
ember 7th or whatever that thing would
be right before Berlin's through like I
mean even if they did it may be the rate
the raid would almost be on the same
damn day as Borderlands 3 you don't talk
about there's not people to be listen I
hear will you come
variable that we didn't have prior to
our argument is Beurling
so that changes things I'm saying I
definitely not prior to that I was comic
gung ho let's go
whoever's whatever you don't say but
this is never this is a serious invasion
to the homeland security of destiny like
this is what it is you know me so at the
end of the day you have to adjust and as
we've seen bigger corporations bigger
Studios have done it you know I'm saying
call of duty has done it I never thought
I would see the day call a duty moved
often over you know I mean and that was
the red benefit again if then hopefully
they don't pull EA right which is
launched on the same day or something
else and you know cross you know I like
their title yeah yeah yeah I'm saying
don't do that so the only way they can
get away with it is if the rumor is true
that is again another season pass an
annual pass structure right I'll be
honest if this this thing again which is
the rumor that we're hearing and pass
again then I really don't care that it
drop if it drops us a time anymore
because it's like it's gonna be light
anyway yeah so it's like all right we
ain't going super super hard
here is something hey guys remember us
you know and then hopefully you have
something else in December and maybe
maybe you do what you say which is kind
of like back loaded right so maybe the
first one is kind of like you know you
get another kind of black for its kind
of thing you know the armed black army
kind of thing and then you know just
enough to kind of keep you in a gameplay
loop and then as you go on you get a
maybe I'll add a little bit a little bit
more a little bit more I just need them
to finish strong
that's all I'm saying cuz at the end of
the day I know you what's your point and
you're not gonna beat this because we
know how we get it'll be the last words
last row on point and would be here
forever
August oh nice discussion but what out
what I'm gonna say is that it's so
imperative to keep engaged it's so
imperative for quality content because
you got guys like the hardcore look it
Forte in here you know I'm saying you
got drift arena you got these guys in
here who love this game we all love this
game right
and as long as the content is quality
doesn't have to be super crazy like you
know taking King ish you know level but
as long as it's solid and you feel a
sense of enjoyment that's the main thing
you can't all I'm saying is you can't
finish on a very average to you know
revelry you know where we are now you we
can't we can't go ahead like we we even
if we're competing just compete that's
what I compete as best as you can with
the resources you have and and that's
all I'm saying
I give us give us whisper the worm kind
of things give us and I'm saying more of
those give us added their own kind of
things right you do that kind of stuff
and if you can finagle it I'm coming
around right this is this is non-comic
kognito talking right now you know I
missed the comment I am literally
bending the knee to your strategy that I
despise but if we must surrender to
boiling just walked in is like yeah you
gotta surrender we will go amicably will
be peaceful what I surrender will just
give us some engaging content or some
good more and you're like okay cool this
is not mega turn oh my god
you know taking King Thank You yo but
but this was fun and we have fun doing
this we like what you're doing just
don't give us no arc week don't give us
no referee because I will be upset bro
don't don't give us no if you give us
that I will be out here okay let me ask
you I got a I got a speculate now cuz of
what you're asking so you want do you
want good things gotta have the good
things no no like and that's that's what
a lot of people want is that quality
mm-hmm what if you got your comment and
what if okay weird timing situation
let's go is talk you get a mini comment
in January without an annual pass mmm
so basically you got it you got a damn
talk with a lot the live team is just
like literally they would do like
festival lost an iron
and they're like hey we want to wrap
this up we want to give you guys a nice
package to wrap up whatever you're
asking for whether it's a buffoon the
story whatever you got going on and then
you say opulence break of just basically
ultra low-key life service literally
iron banners and maybe festival that's
it and then you get say January some
February something like that you get
your mini comment before whenever they
do d3 but say that's all you get though
but you I mean you watch you want your
package of good things you want your
story you want your new activity you
want those and if you're worried about
the revelries the arc weeks the seasons
of The Drifter which is the Annual Pass
and you take your chunk and put it all
in one but you give them a little more
time to get it in January so what if if
and then they made trickle stuff at
afterwards but your main hits like
February until whatever comes next that
serves yours that gives them a little
time to dodge the you know Borderlands 3
bullet mm-hm how would that sit with I'm
just curious like how would that sit
with you cuz you got like three months
of kind of down down there's time okay
let me before I guess I have to address
to count because we have Lord slow-mo of
the from the realm of Borderlands who's
very arrogant
right now he's he's saying he's bending
the knee he's to the Lord of ludus
shooters he's going in on me he knows my
ego can't take this as bestie fat
bothering me that I have to surrender to
this bed of his gaze he's been he has
been on fire because we had more on it
that the division camp so right now he's
been pumping this boil and I don't like
his arrogant he's he's feeling itself
because I know I'm gonna have to most
likely had to surrender in September but
I'm gonna fight so this what I said
oh yeah dizzy he's another one it's the
truth
we got we gotta surrender but here's the
thing I see when you go with the weight
with a comment until January right what
you say like January February issue yeah
sauna hit hard you can do that and you
can do that but I think you still have
to put something out that month then I
still think that you still have
something yeah you still gotta put even
if it's light right you still gotta put
something out that mom just to say hey I
know you know we're not doing too well
over here
but we're here we have something right
you put some little nostalgic piece is
just tread water just tread water stuff
right get the trailer but it's just a
long as it's a fun gateway that's all
I'm saying it cannot be what drift has
been that's what loads they give us
something fun but you know saying I'm
good with that
oh you know what they could do it yeah I
just thought about it they're sitting on
so many fan favorite things we is
Sparrow racing where is you know I'm
seeing like I didn't want touch fries
you know I thought yeah do you see the
tweet the fake trials tweet not about
was just entities it's a tease it's just
it it was tweeted out somebody changed
their icon it was like this like three
person game mode it's just it looks more
real than it should know it's just like
doesn't mean that real they can
literally not drop no major major
content give back trials put back srl
racing give us some fan favorite things
right that could hold you oh my god says
gonna win it can hold you you get
goodwill from the community right
community see stuff that they love but
love stuff they come back they might
okay cool we're here we'll hold the fort
down until we get the big release until
we prep for d3 and if also just be
transparent all I gotta do is say yo
here's the deal y'all everyone's hands
on deck for destiny three you know with
anticipating a full whatever release we
can just say a saint like Generic like a
fall 2020 or whatever it is so this way
everybody Oh big boys coming see what
you know it mentally in your head you're
okay is when you don't know and then you
getting beat upside the head
poor lives and all these other games I
hate you see that's me what are you
doing what about us that's when you
start to get the dick so as long as they
do that I'm okay with strategy fair
enough mm-hmm like we've kind of hashed
out most of those before
I just I'm at the point to where like
after stepping away and playing other
games like I stepped into division with
my brother and we're kind of going
through the missions things like that
it's okay to step away from the game for
a little while
it is no one I don't think anyone in
check and tell me at some point when you
step away and you play another game that
it almost doesn't refresh your time in
destiny when you do step back into it
you're a good man you're a good Bailey I
keep praying man this how bad I'm
fiending like I'm finding excuses to
play the game I love when there's
literally no real new cut that I've
really enjoyed and that's finding people
as much I want to play that's the thing
is if they like if if you step away
those times when you're like I don't
wanna play rebel or I don't wanna play
wherever lay and there's this whole
thing like itching at your head and it's
like you still made you come back and
play iron banner to a point of almost
didn't come back the last time and then
you know and that's one of those things
like that's some of the issue of
progressive vote for giving division a
shot I wasn't not gonna give it a shot I
just was playing SEC hero first actually
that one just took me it's just the
point like you look what Borderlands did
taking a giant break and Destiny's never
gonna do that until the franchise is
done it's never gonna be that far but it
is one of those pieces to where the
whole live service piece we see all
these studios whether it's like epic
games like basically killing themselves
to try and stick with the live service
model of fortnight to a point of like
unhealthy and things like that you see
what Red Dead did for the crunches and
things there's a point where sometimes
the like were spoiled as gamers to this
point with the live service model with
our expectation of always having content
when we used to just like wait for
another Mario game or a Zelda game and
you have so much time in between and
there's one source like it's okay to
step away because when you do consider
like if they're gonna relaunch with
something good because we're two years
into this we're on the downhill slide of
destiny to wish whatever you wanna call
it like whatever we do get is gonna be
like the not the fanservice that's more
of an Avengers server but it is gonna be
that thing to basically hold people over
so I mean I that's why I was wondering
because if you go annual pass but you're
not happy with the
you'll pass pieces you get waiting until
you get a bigger chunk that you are
happy with and then they're like break
time kind of like old d1 where you're
gonna have a drought but then you get
some back and that's kind of yeah we've
talked about both and it's just kind of
I very curious to see what they do the
thing is II they can do this annual pass
right but it's just gotta be better it's
just we got we can demand a little
better that's that's all I'm saying
and at the end of the day as far as the
go away thing you are a good man
that's gonna be my expression you're a
good here's the thing I love this game
I love the shooting of this game I love
how it makes me fear I love everything
about this game Cosmetics fun
cooperative play so again when I play
these other games right if you're
wondering why like why don't you just
play ever stuff and I try I literally do
I play other things right yeah but the
problem is nothing gives me that feeling
you know saying so it's hard to go away
with something for extended periods of
time when nothing else gives me their
feeling there are other things to me or
like distractions you know to and I know
a lot of the hardcore destiny guys feel
that way so it's just like it's just
it's a tough thing when you wanna play
something right really love it but it's
not in the best state you know same
didn't see what I see the problem what
happens and I know how this is what it
really is and I think seek free side
freed made it and Forte me wait what
happens is then when you go away you
unless you start really enjoying
yourself yeah outside the married life
it's very difficult to come back when
you go away for a while and something
really enraptured you whether it be war
lands or division or what second role
whatever it is right see okay second was
one and done so you're good but the
worst-case scenario for me is really
getting interests into something else
cuz I know me and that scares me cuz I
don't want to ever say that about I
don't ever want to say I don't want to
say those word but I know me I don't
care what you're playing if they say d3
you're gonna buy
yeah but that's too long that's but but
that's the point
you if you there's a d3 you're going to
play that game I get that but the masses
won't that's the problem and we need
people to play with ii-if them if it's
just us the mass is not it's gonna be
spooky out here if people people will be
so disgusted that name just a thought
hearing of the game there oh that game
yeah like who plays that it'll be the
house they're gonna depart for chunks
here and there like Borderlands is gonna
pull the masses mm-hmm away like the
masses are gonna step away or bad no you
can't leave on a bad note you can't end
the show with a stinker and then try to
come back say hey guys feel real like
knife and we remember okay so what if
well that's why I was saying if you just
get that content in January that's good
but you wait three months to get it as
opposed to you want something in
September October what if that leaves
you as a stinker and you're like I don't
want the rest of it know what I've
already conceded we've bent the knee to
borderlands away you can stop rubbing it
in dienes no no but I'm just saying but
you get nothing until like January
February what a room I'm gonna believe
the rumor the rumor is that its annual
passing on us yeah yeah I'm like they I
think that would be most part at this
point to move whatever their biggest
chunk is till later though at this point
oh yeah yeah that's the thing it shot
the four tab playing warframe every day
for three years then destiny I haven't
played warframe since that's my point
this is this is the thing I'm gonna give
you quick quick history I know it was
supposed to be a short show he's dead my
history was halo right when Hayden came
out that thing changed my life I've
never played anything like that I played
that thing religiously and the
multiplayer was outstanding right then
this thing came courting one called call
of duty modern warfare and I seen my
entire friends schism out of Halo and it
was never the same
it was never the same like that's what
ends up happening as much as I hear it
used to be and what happens with stuff
like that is when the new killing of
black comes
that means you and people don't come
back that's just what it is you don't
say it's the it's the it's the cycle the
thing is destiny has been this unusual
game that it can have these lows and
then magically resurrect itself all I'm
saying is we got to be careful with
playing with fire and doing this Phoenix
analogy because if you keep crashing and
burning there's gonna be a town people
don't care if you do a self raise all I
mean and that's why I've said that about
destiny to a lot of people don't care
about it anyway mm-hmm
so it's like you're not gonna win a lot
of people back with smullin you'll pass
it's like they're literally doing that
as mini fanservice so they're there
player based the quantity of people
they're making whatever content between
September whatever comes after the
annual pass until whatever is possibly
in the future d3 that piece of content
is for probably a very very small base
and will be even smaller as things go
out so it's like then you got to figure
out how much money do they spend on that
smaller on that content for a smaller
base which is an important base those
are your still your leaders who are
going to help bring people to you like
hyped up and stuff like that so they are
still important people to the base but
in turn it's like how much is in a
business sake how much money do you
spend on like the smaller piece when you
know you have to like you know the other
piece is gonna be your chance at a
larger plan this stuff yeah we gotta
give them this is not like we're just
waking up anyway what are we gonna do it
is they like this stuff they've been
working on this stuff for a while it's
just again we're speculating on stuff
that they've probably already cemented
that's already I have a map they just
have not told us and all I would say I
just want to know tell us yep tell us
let us know once we have an idea if they
they could get away with your strategy
and say hey all hands on deck III 2024
right and this is what we're gonna be
doing in the meantime
and you okay like stuff as much as we
won't like the life stuff as much we're
cool because in the back of our head we
know the boys coming but when you don't
talk right and that's what's going on
right now
it's it's a ding you know shout out to
slow-mo he said hey I'll
he said how people leave your game is
very important they are going to leave
your game whether you want them to or
not but how you leave determines whether
they my man return determines whether
they return for a sequel or district
that's what I'm saying just end it nice
quality content not now they got to be
the biggest you know I'm conceding not
to you eat but it's got to be quality
it's got to be that fun factor with
smiling we let y'all that was a cool way
I remember when they did a to triumph
before we were like y'all feels memories
you like yo I'm with it
you're gonna saying that's what you want
you you don't want like put it this way
if they said there's now all hands on
deck for d3 after this stinker of a deal
that's all that's my point those like
what is like if you're saying it's like
okay so d3 is gonna be bigger like what
if opulence is great
okay uncle it's is great last piece cool
it's been a longest time in the in the
oven that one comes out good and that's
what slow-mo saying it's like they can
leave your game disappointed like if
they left after season The Drifter like
a lot of people would or if you leave
after that and you have the annual pass
that has this I feel like it's a dice
roll like every season because we don't
know how they're gonna be which one is
the one that people are gonna like wit
but it's like the more of those you have
the more odds you have that somebody's
gonna get to a point where they're like
this one sucks them out but it's cool as
long as they say hey man that's like
your hold on I want to say was like one
through four you're saying two different
paths you're like it has to be really
good content yeah big no-no but you have
to be well that's fine but like but not
but again the way the season pass is
gone if it's something they're not gonna
do like the full like strike and
crucible map and like story content
charges at the time so if whatever phase
of the annual past doesn't set well and
you fall off is that gonna leave that
bad taste for you or someone else or
someone else
we accept mediocrity from this annual
pass structure now I'm again I'm bending
the knee to it however it like put it
this way we
see we see let's look at each one
individually right black armory story
new trash lore and trash can play new I
feel is good right I felt somewhat you
know at least I enjoy grinding Luke
getting those good rolls getting your
best blast furnace doing all that stuff
okay cool
and we got a rain was the raid the
greatest not necessary but it was solid
it was a solid rate so I think what they
got to do is they've got the information
you can give us the gameplay loop of
black armory and a raid right and give
us some Lord of things drifter did do
well was a little bit of the lore pieces
right you know I'm saying it did some
good things but at the end of the day
they can still you mean to tell me even
if they don't want to do a refresh right
you can still do what you did like at
the end with old remember with that
start that big crazy cinema do cool
things like that without a comment you
can still pull it off you know I'm
saying so they're capable they I think
this experiment was it was an experiment
let's call it what it is they've got the
feedback that we don't like this part of
this experiment we don't like that part
just take that combine it and I still
think they could be able to put out a
quality Annual Pass product that's what
I'm saying I don't think it's mutually
exclusive that it has to be big for it
to be quality as what I said that's fair
and I think sometimes just them on this
like weekly cycle is almost much almost
too much yeah yeah sometimes it's like
it's got to be a little tad bit here
they're like you know every two or three
like spread but as you said little
slightly larger nuggets out like out two
or three weeks truth right like spread
some of the like make things a little
bigger but make them a little far
they're supposed to babe every band but
all the little tiny things in the middle
suck like absolutely so something like
that so what is what is III know I was
like all I'm doing okay oh then when is
he very soon oh we're talking I'm flying
like a wind after whoopsies accomplices
are like the weekend of the aid and then
I the actual event of III is probably
like the
11th of June 13th or something like that
you had a Tuesday yeah so I mean we'll
have season the opulence before it
starts
mm-hmm have your chance to play that oh
man people who the rate of the Raiders
because if you go June 4th and if they
do they're three days on Friday of June
7th and you're saying the conference's
start say yeah I'm gonna miss out
actually I'm not cuz your boy got
destiny only his 1060 laptop whoo so I
will be bringing this bad boy out there
33 shining y'all that sneeze on his bad
boy so we need good I know if I'm be
rain ready
but I'll be good
slow Moe's got another piece too
but yeah so we've got ya like III coming
they'll probably let some of that night
down at some point they've got to tell
us what the fall is gonna have because
it does sound like that's the time to
dump the news whether it's around e3
whether they do their own stream with
something in there or they're gonna let
some of season of opulence play out and
talk about in July I don't know but I
just want to know what the hell's gonna
happen so at this point we're just we've
speculated a lot we've done this
recently because there's only so much
the 12 is as short as it as possibly
ever been there were a few patch notes
and honestly it's not really anything
worth covering so absolutely just
literally our blessed is going to be in
the loop who after thank God that's what
I'm getting it it's not that bad
honestly if you just want to knock it
out it's really not that bad for them no
I'll use my fated Engram thank you it's
not gonna be in that for a little while
Holly that's no like we're not missing
much so you're fair I know
oh that's why don't I don't wanna go
crazy out but shout out to our set freed
and vagabond Oh going at it chat really
funny he's like hey I've been not
playing and playing other things I've
been doing it I would say look we got to
see what's gonna happen i I do feel good
about opulence I just want to know how
they gonna attack it yeah well there's a
big swinger in September we'll see what
happens with it
it honestly like and that's the point to
some always having
thing like this is gonna have like every
single month having something in destiny
at some point it's okay to take a little
like we're gonna breathe for the month
let things settle then we're gonna do
stuff in October so September just gonna
be a chill month so like if that's the
case then you know take your metals yeah
got it Tommy that's it those are no
radio sounds just communicate which you
base that speaks wonders well I've got a
run this morning guys this was gonna
definitely be a shorter one but there
was a lot to talk about anthem is truly
just it's it's gonna be it's gonna be
set on a shelf for a while and that's
just gonna take some time to see what
comes of it I'll be working through
division two with my brother a little
bit but another time so I'll be playing
some other things too like salt and
sanctuary and things like that so just
to try other other things but it is it
was nice yesterday playing with some
people and in gambit working on titles
and stuff like that knocking out some
pinnacle weapons that was cool I enjoyed
that so it still always got those
moments when things come together
just sometimes legs a little while for
things to come together yeah a gameplay
loop was always gonna be what it'd be I
got said in reference to anything where
I played I guess we that live team is
invested and they're really putting out
a lot you know I'm saying a continent
and then as far as our destiny yeah we
got to see September's a fun little
month to analyze you know Borland's is
coming out strong and they looking you
know looking good well we gotta see what
the audacity of a Bungie how they're
tapping I'm so curious about how the end
of the year wraps up right like how they
go about navigating all these the end
doing it as their own entity like its
I'm so curious about this like how are
they planning like really really really
curious yeah I was like they don't I
mean there are people in the world of
Activision that make good and bad
decisions but they've been doing it for
a while in the publisher world dodging
like messing with this type of stuff and
Bungie is like we got to figure this out
on our own so it's gonna be interesting
so I was like I mean sure they're not
dumb people they a lot of them have been
in the gaming world for so long they've
seen a lot of things I will just see how
they play their cards I'm very
very curious as well and the the months
ahead will be interesting mm-hmm but I
don't think after Tuesday I don't think
we have anything left in the world of
season The Drifter yeah I was like I
think that the exotic quest was
basically just the árboles to my
knowledge I don't think there's gonna be
a separate one so for now guys work on
your checklists enjoy if you do want to
step away for a week or two check out
other things that's okay
and we'll know more about opulence
probably in a few weeks but we'll still
be doing these and of course well you'll
miss the e3 one yeah things like that
but we will be out we'll be a guardian
con see if you guys are going we will be
a guardian yes sir
all right have an awesome one everybody
thank you for tuning in we got to work
on this timing my outro I know I know
but I was just saying when we get there
we're gonna work on this timing so I'll
try and get it right it's real quick you
already Lamia core kognito on Twitter
you know I'm saying I know a podcast
every Sunday
you don't say 1:00 p.m. Eastern we
should have a good one y'all she has
some returning guests working on a guest
that's industry industry insider guides
innate by the name Bob Ainsley Bowden so
he should be dropping some Nuggets but
he had he may have to play a hockey game
so we can't I got my pencil he's on
pencil right now so we got to see but it
we may have some really juicy nuggets of
five a lot of stuff going on so please
check this out it's gonna be late Sunday
1:00 p.m. on our little podcast YouTube
and also on our Channel you got Lord
King Day with a king of statues he's got
some amazing amazing pieces right now he
knows Hawkman almost oh you gotta check
it out if you're a fan of comics if
you're a fan of statues please check out
the king of statues do you already know
yeah for me you guys know I'll be
streaming just off and on and playing
this and seeing what comes next but yeah
just mostly like streaming what got my
youtube videos come in sir obviously
will be delayed today mostly just
because I'm not gonna be home till about
6 o'clock so try and get it up as soon
as I get home don't expect anything
crazy invitations of the nine as well
are delayed
still at least till Tuesday but they are
supposed to be fixed on the patch on
Tuesday a little mini patch but outside
of that that's it for me as well so for
your two gentlemen here talking about
your looter shooters this is a little
last word have a good on everybody we'll
see you soon have a good one be big